the number e has all sorts of amazing
properties just as a review you can
define it in terms of a limit the limit
as n approaches infinity of 1 plus 1
over n to the nth power you could also
define it as the limit as n approaches 0
of 1 plus n
to the 1 over nth power
but what we're going to focus on this
video is an amazing property of e and e
has many many amazing properties but
this is the one that's maybe most
relevant to calculus and that's the
notion that if i take the derivative
with respect to x
of e to the x
that it is equal to drum roll it's equal
to e to the x
that to me is amazing let's just
appreciate it for a second before we
actually prove it this is part of the
graph of y is equal to e to the x and so
what this says is the derivative of e to
the x for any x is equal to e to the x
the slope of the tangent line at any
point here is equal to the value of the
function let's just appreciate that so
right over here the value of the
function is 1 and the slope of the
tangent line is 1. here the value of the
function is 2 and the slope of the
tangent line is 2. here the value of the
function is 4 and the slope of the
tangent line is equal to 4. so i could
just go on this is just another amazing
thing about e and we'll see many more in
calculus but let's now prove that this
is actually true so let's just use our
definition of a derivative so the
derivative with respect to x
of e
to the x would be the limit
of delta x or as delta x approaches 0 of
e to the x plus delta x
minus e to the x
all of that over
all of that over delta x now let's do
some algebraic manipulation here to see
if we can make some sense of it
so this is going to be equal to
the limit
as delta x approaches zero
of let's see what happens well i won't
skip any steps here this is the same
thing as e to the x
times e to the delta x this is just
using our exponent properties here minus
e to the x
over
delta x just to be clear i rewrote
this right over here
as this right over here
now i can factor out an e to the x and
in fact because the e to the x is not
affected as the as delta x approaches 0
i can factor the e to the x out of the
entire limit so let's do that let's take
the e to the x
out of the entire limit let's factor it
let's factor it completely out it does
not get affected by the delta x
so this is going to be equal to
factor that e to the x out
e to the x times the limit
as delta x approaches 0
of e to the delta x
minus 1
all of that over
delta x
so now we're going to get a little bit
fancy with our limits we're going to do
what's known as a change of variable so
i'm going to say let's see i don't know
how to directly find this limit right
over here but maybe i can simplify it
and who knows maybe i can get it into
one of these forms up here
so what if i were to make the
substitution
and let me do it over here let's say i
would make the substitution that n
is equal to e to the delta x
minus 1.
so what would this be if we were to
solve for delta x let's see we could add
1 to both sides n plus 1 is equal to e
to the delta x
to solve for delta x we could just take
the natural logarithm log base e of both
sides and we would get the natural log
of n plus 1
is equal to delta x
and so
we can make that substitution this
could be replaced with this and what we
have in the numerator over here can be
replaced with
n right over there
and what would happen to the limit well
as delta x
approaches zero
what does n approach so delta x
approaches zero implies that n
approaches what let's see as delta x
approaches zero this would be e to the
zero which is one minus one so it looks
like n approaches zero and you can look
at it over here as n approaches zero
right over here natural log of zero plus
one natural log of one that is 0. so as
each of them as delta x approaches 0 and
approaches 0 as n approaches 0 delta x
approaches 0. so then you can replace if
you make the change of variable from
delta x to n you could still say as n
approaches 0. so let me rewrite all of
this
that was the fanciest step in this
entire thing that we're about to do
so it's going to be e to the x
times the limit
since we changed our variable it's now
going to be as n approaches 0 because as
delta x approaches zero n approaches
zero and vice versa and this numerator
here we said hey that's going to be
equal to n
n
over
delta x is now the natural log of n plus
one
natural log of n plus 1.
now what does that do for us
well what if we were to divide the
numerator and the denominator by n
so let's multiply down here by 1 over n
and let's multiply up here by 1 over n
well our numerator is just going to be
equal to 1 and what does our denominator
equal
well here we can just use our exponent
properties all of this is going to be
equal to
this is going to be equal to
we have our e to the x out front e to
the x
and then we have
the limit
as n approaches zero our numerator is
now one
over
now i'm going to rewrite
this just using our logarithm properties
if i have i'll do it right over here if
i have a times the natural log of b this
is the same thing as the natural log of
b
to the a power the eighth power this is
just natural log properties so we have
down here this would be the same thing
as the natural log
of
n plus one and actually let me write it
the other way around one plus n
one plus n i just swapped these two
to the one over n power so the natural
log of that whole thing
now you might be getting that tingly
feeling because something is starting to
look familiar
what i just constructed inside the
logarithm here looks an awful lot like
what we have right over here and limit
as n approaches zero limit as n
approaches zero
in fact we can use our limit properties
this one isn't affected what's really
affected is what's inside the logarithm
so we could say that this is going to be
equal to
and we're approaching our drum roll e to
the x
times
1 over
1
over
the natural log i'll do that blue color
the natural log of
i'll give myself some space
the limit
the limit
as n
approaches zero
of
this business right over here which i
could just write as
1 plus n to the 1 over nth power
so this is really interesting
what is this what did i just what do i
have there in the denominator with this
limit what is this thing equal to
well we already said that is a
definition of e
that is this right over here
which is equal to this over here
so this is equal to e
so what does this all boil down to
i think you see where this is going but
this is fun we're downhill from here
this is e to the x
times
1 over
the natural log
the natural log of
e
well the natural log of e what power do
i have to raise e to get to e well i
just have to raise it to 1.
so this gets us
e
to the x and we're done we've just
proven that the derivative with respect
to x of e to the x is indeed equal to e
to the x
that's an amazing finding that shows us
one more dimension of the beauty of the
number e